-Wow.
It looks good on you, bud.
-Thank you.
-Are you used to wearing it?
-Yeah, now, after today, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
You're going to college at Yale,
so you're a college student.
-Right.
-Really, yeah.
And now you got to go back
to college.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Yep.
-Yeah, but you just won
the gold medal in the Olympics.
How are you going to do this?
You can't wear this
around campus.
-No, no, absolutely not.
It's going to be great.
I mean,
I'm pretty excited for that,
back to
-Going back to
-[Both] normal life.
-What else are you excited
about, taking naps?
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, absolutely.
I mean, I just got back
from Beijing
like last night, so.
-Do you have any idea
where you are?
-No, I have no idea.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
I was rooting for you,
obviously,
going into the Olympics and I
was like, "Oh, my gosh."
I go, "I want this kid
to nail it."
And you go out there
and I've never seen anything
more beautiful in my life.
You were unbelievable.
-Thank you.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-It was almost like watching
a magic trick or something.
Because I've never seen --
You jump up.
They call you the Quad King.
-[ Laughs ]
-Because you do four spins
and then land.
Does it matter what skate
you land on?
-Generally, yeah.
So, if you are right-handed,
you generally always land
on your right.
But there are some exceptions
to that.
There are some athletes that are
like able to do it both ways,
but I just land on my right.
-How do you know
that you can do that?
I mean, obviously,
you practice and try,
[ Laughter ]
but I mean --
-Right, right.
-Do you know,
once you spring up,
that it's going to work
or not work?
-Generally yeah, yeah.
I would say like,
more often than not,
athletes will go into the jump
and then if it happens
to go the way that we want,
you'll see it work.
Right off the takeoff,
if something goes awful,
bail out and so,
instead of doing four revs,
we'll do like maybe two
or three revolutions.
But, yeah, that'll be a big
error, if we were to do that.
-And now, when that happens,
are you just bummed
for the rest of the routine?
[ Laughter ]
Because you go,
"I'm not going to win the gold
at this point."
And then you're like trying
to smile and go,
"Yeah, this is my thing,
but, yeah, I messed up."
-To an extent, I would say yes.
You have to like put on a smile
and be like, "Whatever,
I have to finish it."
-Yeah.
Are you hard on yourself?
-Yeah, I'd say so.
I mean,
we're all pretty competitive,
so we want to do well.
-Yeah. Did you get to see
what you did
or do you not watch
what you did?
-I have, yeah, I did.
I got to watch it.
-It was unbelievable.
-Thank you.
Nathan Chen.
[ Cheering and applause ]
It was insane.
Perfection.
It was like well done.
How many jumps are there
in skating?
-There are six jumps.
There are
Axel, salchow, toe loop,
loop, flip, and Lutz.
But minor details
between the six.
-And can you do any of the jumps
when you're not wearing skates?
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, like to an extent, yes.
-I mean --
[ Cheering and applause ]
This might be the first time
we've had a gold medalist
on the show.
I mean, would you be able
-Sure.
-to do a jump on our show?
-Sure, yeah.
You could probably do an Axel.
[ Cheering and applause ]
I'll put this down really quick.
-Sure.
-Give this to you.
-Oh, I'll take it.
Don't worry about it.
Yeah, I got this.
Don't worry about that.
-So, yeah,
you could do like a single Axel,
where you step in, jump,
rotate, and land.
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
So, basically, that's that.
But we do that like times three.
So we do the same thing,
but rotate three times
and then do that on the ice.
-I could try one,
but you'd have to show me.
-Please, please, please.
[ Cheering and applause ]
I would love to.
I'd love to.
-Slow motion, what do you do?
-Alright.
So this is called an Axel.
This is the one jump that we
take off going forward.
Everything else goes backwards.
-Axel goes forward.
-You start off on the right.
-Yeah.
-Step forward on the left.
Kick through.
And you rotate and then land
on your right.
-So it's kind of like
the Electric Slide.
Yeah, I understand.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Alright.
-So let's like break it down.
-When do you go up?
-Instead of doing a full rev,
we'll just do half a rev.
-Thank you.
-So you go here, jump up,
jump, and land.
[ Cheering and applause ]
There it is.
There, there it is.
[ Rimshot ]
-Here, you deserve this more
than I do.
This is the one and only
Nathan Chen right there.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Olympic gold medalist.